well that's happened in the last 10
years
it's a miracle I'm even sitting here now
I got a second chance
I'm going to take advantage of that
but I need you with me Pete
you're gonna Heal the World
[Music]
guys this is my best friend Harry hey
good to meet you good job huh still
gonna have time for tutoring we'll
figure it out
I didn't know there were bears in these
Woods
AMJ I have another name for you Craven
he's here on some kind of hunt
you know if you need me I'm just a call
away
know what you took for me
well miles talks about is how to be a
better Spider-Man
you what the hell is going on with me
he's not himself go help him
this was our dream
we're going to heal the world
[Music]